desde muy pequeña tuve la gran fortuna
de descubrir mi vocación quizás cuando
apenas tenía siete años vengo trabajando
desde esa edad en los sectores más
necesitados y vulnerables de nuestra
sociedad especialmente en venezuela mi
país de origen desde esa época comencé
en el mundo de las ongs de las
organizaciones sin fines de lucro
trabajando mucho luego incursionar en el
sector público por varios años y esta
carrera me llevó finalmente a ser
banquero yo siempre digo de los ricos
terminé en nueva york trabajando muchos
años en la banca hasta que decidí en el
año 2006 regresar a venezuela para
fundar la banca comunitaria una banca
ahora de los pobres destinada a proveer
servicios financieros a todos aquellos
que nunca antes habían tenido la
posibilidad de tener acceso a algún
producto algún servicio a tener una
cuenta de ahorros o un crédito esa foto
que está allí me trae muchísimos
recuerdos porque ese señor que ven allí
de camisa roja es carlos arias el primer
cliente
comunitarias
carlos igual que el 57% de los
venezolanos pertenecía al sector
informal
todos esos microempresarios que trabajan
muy duramente pero que a la vez
pertenecen a una clase que no ha podido
nunca lograr formalizar su empresa o
hacer que todo sea desde el punto de
vista legal organizado pero él sin
embargo pues luchaba duro para tener su
empresa sacarla adelante una bodega que
tenía en el sector oeste de la ciudad en
la vega en una comuna como le llaman
ustedes donde con junto a su familia
trabajaba muy arduamente por hacerla
crecer
él tenía dos empleados familiares de él
pero también informales y bueno no se
imaginan la alegría que carlos tenía
cuando recibió ese crédito junto a su
esposa y a un cuñado que le sirvió como
fiador él como tantos soñaba con hacer
crecer su negocio y seguir adelante
yo aprendí muchísimo de los
emprendedores muchísimo de esos
microempresarios que día a día luchaban
por salir adelante con sus pequeños
negocios de su resiliencia de su
capacidad de adaptarse de su
flexibilidad ante tantas circunstancias
que eran complejas y cambios muy
dinámicos por los cuales ellos tenían
que atravesar nosotros más de siete años
hicimos estudios econométricos para
demostrar que había pasado con esos
microcréditos que habíamos entregado
esos microempresarios cuál era el efecto
cuál era el impacto que ocasionaban y
logramos redescubrir digamos que el 80%
de esos microempresarios podían mantener
a sus hijos en la escuela el 20 por
ciento de esos microempresarios eran
capaces de producir dos empleos
informales generalmente entre sus
familiares y también descubrimos que
ellos podían accesar a servicios
privados de salud y mejorar las
condiciones muchas veces de su vivienda
sin embargo algunos de esos
microempresarios no podían sino como les
decía generar empleos informales no eran
capaces de dar condiciones formales para
eso que formaban parte de sus equipos y
en ese año 2013 7 años luego de haber
comenzado esa banca comunitaria
fui a la presentación de café el banco
de desarrollo para américa latina donde
presentaba un estudio que se llamaba
emprendimiento en américa latina'
justamente en nuestra región asistí con
mucha atención y ese estudio lo que
básicamente decía era que si bien en
nuestra región la gente es muy
emprendedora el 75% de esos
emprendimientos eran unipersonales o
microempresarios emprendimientos que no
eran formales y que por lo tanto no eran
capaces de verdaderamente generar
productividad incidir en lo que es el
desarrollo económico del país
quedaban fuera nadie los tomaba en
cuenta porque la verdad es que no
incidían en la economía
me quedé
muy emocionada pues con lo que
significaba eso porque yo trabajaba con
ellos y los sentía muy duramente pero
bueno justamente en ese año 2013 me tocó
y decidí hacer un posgrado un estudio en
amsterdam en una escuela de liderazgo
creativo donde tenía que ingresar con un
proyecto de aceleración yo había
escuchado hablar de los impact caps y
estaba sumamente interesada por cómo
hacer que esa red mundial llegará a
venezuela cómo podría yo traer el
impacto a caracas y decidí entrar en
zinc con esa idea como desarrolló el
impact hub en caracas
me debatía seis meses con esa gran
pregunta que me destruía la mente cómo
seguir generando impacto cómo podía
generar mayor impacto seguía con un gran
número de emprendedores con impacto
quizás más pequeños o me concentraban
pocos emprendedores pero trataba de
producir un impacto mucho más fuerte
decidí finalmente abrir el impacto
caracas en el año 2014 nos encontrábamos
listos para abrir sus puertas
era un 13 de febrero la fecha que
habíamos escogido para su inauguración
la noche antes el día 12 de febrero que
celebramos el día de la juventud tuvimos
que suspender la inauguración
ese día los estudiantes habían salido a
marchar habían salido a protestar por
sus derechos como siempre lo hacían ese
día de la juventud como ustedes saben
pues no había acceso a la educación no
había posibilidades de tener libre
prensa había mucha censura los
estudiantes también reclamaban por la
hiperinflación que estábamos viviendo y
ese día tres estudiantes fueron
asesinados por la guardia nacional
la ciudad se convirtió en el caos más
terrible que ustedes puedan imaginar
habían bombas lacrimógenas por todos
lados gases detonaciones y en el medio
de ese desastre nosotros nos debatíamos
qué hacer sin embargo nos dio chance
quizás de hacer un experimento de wii
framing como reorganizar ese caos para
hacerlo productivo para poder crear
soluciones en medio de ese desastre como
hacíamos un espacio que verdaderamente
reuniera a todos los sectores para
dialogar profundamente en los problemas
que la sociedad nos estaba poniendo en
la cara
y justamente después de tres meses el 15
de mayo hace 5 años de ese año logramos
abrir el impacto logramos abrir sus
puertas el impacto caracas es una
comunidad de emprendimiento que promueve
el impacto transformador el triple
impacto financiero social y ambiental
entre todos los emprendedores que estén
comprometidos con el desarrollo
sostenible y no solamente tiene lugar en
caracas se hace en el mundo entero
tenemos 102 impactos en el mundo
haciendo esto
conseguimos un concepto que nos gustó
mucho y fue el concepto de middle out
entrepreneurs' o le llamamos los
emprendedores del medio como esos
emprendedores que estaban en el centro
de la pirámide podían generar impacto
hacia abajo impacto hacia sus lados pero
también impacto hacia arriba que
realmente fuera sostenible y justamente
trabajando con ellos después de mucho
tiempo descubrimos cinco años más tarde
con estos 202 emprendedores que tenemos
en el impact hub haciendo parte que el
90% de ellos ha sido capaz de generar 8
empleos en promedio sin embargo un
amplio porcentaje de ellos también ha
generado 22 puestos nuevos de trabajo y
además el 17 por ciento de ellos ha
creado lo que llaman una pura invención
algo totalmente novedoso algún producto
o algún servicio que no existía antes en
el mundo 55% de ellos ha logrado
incrementar sus ingresos
13 por ciento en el doble de sus veces y
lo mejor de todos es que todos y cada
uno de ellos está comprometido con
generar impacto a través de algunos de
los objetivos de desarrollo sostenible
algunos de estos ejemplos les quiero
compartir city wallet es una iniciativa
de pago de micro pago alternativo que se
utiliza a través de una calcomanía una
tarjeta o un brazalete el diálogo que
propone city wallet es entre los
ciudadanos comunes y la tecnología por
supuesto para los expertos se fundamenta
en block change se fundamenta nfc pero
es una simple brazalete una simple
calcomanía que tú utilizas para pagar y
eso ha hecho que se ahorre más de un
millón de facturas que no se tienen que
imprimir que las personas ahorren más de
21 millones de minutos no haciendo
ninguna fila para pagar y que eso se
transforme en más de 25 mil usuarios que
ya han comenzado a usar esta forma de
pago
tenemos también el caso de kaká o el un
diálogo que presenta kaká y hoy un
aceite que sirve para el
rejuvenecimiento de la piel para la
humectación y que se produce de una nuez
que solamente existe en venezuela y en
colombia kaká y hoy ha sido capaz apenas
en sus inicios de reforestar 1.200
árboles por cada botella de cacao que se
compra un dólar va destinado a plantar
un nuevo álbum árbol de cacao que tarda
30 años en crecer
tenemos también o del jazz o del jazz es
un emprendimiento que pretende
representar talento artístico y cultural
en nuevos mercados como el mercado de
norteamérica o el mercado europeo han
logrado ya presentar 250 músicos en 100
países en más de 100 shows en más de 20
países y ellos a su vez han tenido la
oportunidad de tener nuevos ingresos que
les permiten seguir prosperando en sus
pequeñas comunidades donde nunca antes
habían salido el diálogo que propone o
delia es entre los ancestros y la
actualidad es ver traer esos tambores
africanos de nuestros orígenes al mundo
de hoy y ha permitido también que esos
músicos conozcan su adn de dónde viene
quiénes eran verdaderamente sus pueblos
de dónde se originaron sus ancestros
para terminar quiero contarles una
leyenda
una leyenda p mona de la etnia pemón a
el orinoco que es ese río amarillo que
ustedes ven allí debe su color a las
aguas sedimentadas que arrastra desde la
amazona es donde nace este río y el
caroní que es ese río negro que ustedes
ven allí tiene su color negro
precisamente porque arrastra caminos
desde el huc henán el tepuy donde nace
en el parque canaima cuenta esa leyenda
que estos ríos representan dos amantes
que pertenecían a tribus distintas que
se enamoraron y luchaban por estar
juntos pero que sus etnias y sus tribus
diferentes no lo dejaban juntarse
precisamente porque no pertenecían a la
misma tribu ellos decidieron arrojarse
al mar arrojarse primero al río
juntarse y el mar el océano atlántico
los acogió en un abrazo eterno que pudo
sellar su amor para siempre
yo los invito a pensar en cómo podemos
aprender del río caroní y del río
orinoco quizás nosotros no podemos ser
capaces de controlar o evitar alguna
crisis o algún conflicto grave en
nuestros países pero lo que sí podemos
hacer es abrazarnos como estos ríos es
aprender a dialogar profundamente es
crear espacios de encuentro desde cada
uno de nosotros desde lo que puede hacer
así como con fluye el emprendimiento y
así como el emprendimiento nos invita a
dialogar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]